cleveland's major league baseball team
says it took the name
indians in 1915 as a tribute to a native
american player but now after years of
protests
that name will be dropped according to
the new york times and in a statement to
cbs news
the team did not dispute that report
national correspondent erika duncan
looks now at the recent reckoning with a
name
that some say is racist we're never
trying to be disrespectful
and i still feel that way but i don't
think
that's a good enough answer today
that was cleveland manager terry
francona in july
saying he believed it was time for his
team to move forward from its longtime
indian's nickname now it seems that time
has come we've been engaged in those
conversations over the course of the
last
several months two weeks ago team
president chris antonetti confirmed his
club had been reevaluating its name
a process that appeared to begin shortly
after the washington nfl team
formerly known as the redskins dropped
its name over the summer
following washington's announcement
cleveland released a statement pledging
to keep improving on issues of social
justice with its team name in mind
this isn't cleveland's first time
confronting controversial parts of its
team history
it feels really good that steps are
being taken that
our voices are being heard phillip yenyo
is executive director of the american
indian movement of ohio
he led several protests against the
team's long time chief wahoo logo
which cleveland officially removed at
the start of the 2019
season once chief wahoo went away i just
think it was the
the the rock was rolling down the hill
and it wasn't going to be stopped
jack horgan spent 17 years as
cleveland's television announcer
and grew up there as an indians fan i
think there's an awareness
of trying to find something that that is
appealing to all
and offensive to none i commend major
league baseball for
looking at the process because if there
are enough people who think that it
is demeaning it's something that that
needs to be addressed
for cbs this morning i'm jerica duncan
it's been a long time coming left us
note that president trump's reaction was
oh no what's going on that's not good
news
even for indians cancel culture at work
well you could look at it as cancel
culture or you could look at it as
making things right for people who've
been offended for a very long long time
yeah yeah just just because it always
was doesn't mean it always has to be
right and doesn't mean it's right it
doesn't mean it's right we have the
capacity to change and in many cases we
should